la medida más llamativa de esta nueva
reforma es la tasa del 33% sobre los
beneficios extraordinarios de las
eléctricas que supone esta medida
respecto a la política energética
anterior de la Unión Europea y qué otras
medidas han anunciado
bueno esta medida es algo que va a dar
una posibilidad de responder a la crisis
energética a corto plazo no va a
permitir a los Estados miembros
redistribuir Los costos de la
problemática les va a permitir apoyar a
sus ciudadanos y a algunas empresas para
poder pagar los costos
de la energía que han aumentado
drásticamente debido a la agresión rusa
en Ucrania y sabemos
algunas otras medidas son más a largo
plazo no como por ejemplo la el previsto
banco europeo de hidrógeno la idea acá
es que el hidrógeno podría facilitar El
reemplazo del gas natural para la
producción de electricidad Pero
obviamente eso es algo que va a tomar
varios años posiblemente dé y bueno es
entonces un refuerzo que va a ser
respaldado por la Unión Europea
lo mismo es el caso para la
implementación de reservas estratégicas
de materias primas eso también va a ser
el caso por ejemplo para tierra sagradas
para metales que son necesarias por
ejemplo para la producción de
electromotores y esas son materias
primas que se producen sobre todo en
China Así que esas medidas No solo son
pensados en el contexto de la guerra en
Ucrania pero también son pensados en el
contexto de la competencia con china Así
que significan básicamente que la Unión
Europea está asumiendo una actitud más
geopolítica frente a su política
económica frente a las diferentes
estructuras de las diferentes
regulaciones de los mercados y
Bueno eso es una buena noticia en el
contexto geopolítico actual seguramente
también importante más a corto plazos
son las medidas para la reducción de
demanda en
episodios de algo muy alta demanda Lo
que sucede es que frecuentemente es el
gas natural que se puede activar o
Desactivar según necesidad es utilizado
para cubrir la demanda en temporadas de
muy alta demanda Así que esa reducción
en toda la Unión Europea no solo va a
reducir la utilización de gas para la
producción de electricidad Pero también
es una medida esencialmente solidaria
entre los estados Sí señor está hablando
precisamente de solidaridad y hoy España
y Portugal han anunciado los buenos
datos de la llamada excepción ibérica
que ha rebajado un 18% el aumento del
coste de la energía supone esto una
victoria de los países del sur de Europa
frente a la postura de otros países
centroeuropeos o las nuevas medidas son
un consenso dentro de la Unión Europea
bueno obviamente
van a costar más a algunos países que a
otros obviamente la situación lamentable
lo que también admitió Sonda Line es
debido a la política errónea de países
como Alemania Italia y algunos otros
Quienes se hicieron depender del
suministro de gas por Rusia sin pensar
en posibles riesgos geopolíticos los que
se volvieron obvios con la invasión de
Rusia en